conservative Brett's eaters have reacted
angrily to the Prime Minister's talks
with Jeremy Corbyn and predicted open
revolts so let's get the views of the
chairman of the euro skeptic group of
conservative MPs the ERG Jacob Riis mark
who joins us now thank you very much for
being with us this morning so does that
fill you with optimism that jeremy
corbyn is now part of the brexit process
I think having Jeremy Corbyn as part of
the brexit process is a mistake that he
is not sympathetic to the government
obviously and as a remainder so what
you've got is to remain as trying to
work out how we should leave ignoring
the seventeen point four million people
who voted to leave and ignoring the fact
that Parliament has legislated not just
once but twice
for us to leave with or without a deal
in both the article 50 act and in the
withdrawal act the things you say that
Parliament has legislated to leave
without a deal but it's also voted
consistently against leaving without a
deal and as Theresa May says this
morning the reason she's had to reach
out to get a compromise for Jeremy
Corbyn it's because she simply can't
rely on conservatives on her own side to
back the deal they forced her hand well
I think that's an odd way of looking at
it the reason the Prime Minister hasn't
been able to get all conservative MPs to
back her deal is that she failed to
deliver on the promises she made in the
Conservative Party manifesto in the
blanks to house speech in the mansion
house speech she came back with a deal
that potentially led to a division
between Great Britain and Northern
Ireland so the reason she's in
difficulties is her own creation it's
not forced upon her but at the same time
the Conservative Party has failed to
back the deal on the table it's failed
to get enough support for a no deal exit
which some on the back benches would
like to see so what is the solution well
I would question the failed to get
enough support for an a deal that you're
quite right the parliament has passed
motions objecting to a no deal breaks it
but it passed a law indeed two laws that
provided us for for us to leave on the
29th of March subsequently delayed and
Lord Trump's motions
the Prime Minister could have taken us
out on the 29th of March to the prime
minister who asked for an extension it
was a prime minister who changed the
date by prerogative power from the 29th
March 12 April there's all rests with
her and upon her shoulders she has made
the Prime Minister mrs. May has made
active choices to stop his leaving and
she deserves to be held to account for
that because people ought to know the
truth of the position rather than trying
to blame everybody else blaming or
counseling MPs and other conservatives
the Prime Minister had done what she'd
said in the first place and had stuck to
the laws set out in two acts we would
have left the European Union by now I
wonder though if actually there is an
argument that conservative brexit is
like yourself do need to shoulder some
of the blame if as many expect the talks
that Jeremy Corbyn lead to a softer
brexit or indeed no breakfast at all I'm
a new consistently whipped opinion
against her reason they still you
described it as risking making Britain a
slave state to the EU of risking paying
39 billion pounds for nothing I mean
it's no surprise she's failed to get the
support when people such as yourselves
have been so opposed to the deal even
though you did have the last-minute
conversion well I've waited for it the
last time out because I thought it was
the least bad option that's absolutely
correct but the least bad option because
of the way decisions are being made by
the government what I said about slave
state and 39 billion for nothing remain
absolutely true that mrs. Mayer's deal
would leave us for 22 hour month subject
to EU law and EU judges without any say
over it at all and paying 39 billion
pounds without any guarantee of a free
trade deal two of the reasons why it's
such a poor deal the greatest reason of
course being the potential to split up
the United Kingdom at the behest of the
EU which is why I said last week that if
we are forced to remain in we should be
the most difficult member possible
because I don't think the EU in its
jargon has behaved towards us with
sincere cooperation i dint think sincere
cooperation could possibly include
trying to break up the unity of a member
state when it leaves the European Union
and therefore I think we no longer
obliged to follow sand circle
operation in return and when the
multi-annual financial framework comes
forward if we're still in this is our
one in seven year opportunity to veto
the budget and to be really very
difficult and I hope that any British
Prime Minister would take that
opportunity can you just spell out I
mean you talked that about vetoing a
budget what exactly do you mean by being
as disruptive as possible well many
things are taken over now by qualified
majority vote and there's nothing we can
do about them in terms of the budget
each annual budget is set by majority
voting but the seven-year budgetary
framework requires unanimity and that we
could veto that we'd also be able to
stop mr. macarons plans for further deep
integration because those would almost
certainly require treaty change so as
they began to progress if we were still
a member we would be able to stop them
so I think it's trying to stop further
integration and trying to ensure that it
doesn't cost us any more money so these
would be things that weren't just
difficult for their own sake but we're
also in the British national interest if
we were still a member state you see
listen to speak it sounds as if we have
an awful lot of power well being a
member of the European Union when I
actually thought that the whole point of
trying to leave was to get sovereignty
we're not I know some people have said
that in response what I said but I don't
think they're looking at the detail and
we can veto the budget one year and
seven for the other years we just have
to take the budget that is delivered
under that framework all our laws on
agriculture on fishing on trade come
from the European Union and we can be
out vated we are one of 28 members that
we can't set our envy 80 system in
detail we can't take v80 of domestic
fuel for example little things like that
that are very important to people's
livelihoods they're set by the European
Union we can't control our borders and
say no no this doesn't undermine the
general view that far too many laws come
from the European Union and that we
don't have democratic control over it
what it does show is that if they keep
us in if they haven't behaved with
sincere cooperation what it sauce for
the goose is sauce for the gander so I
wonder and then we're talking about the
possibility of staying in the European
Union longer
than many people expected are you going
to be voting in the European Parliament
elections or do you think the
Conservative Party should veto them if
they happen oh well if we're still in of
course we should have European elections
that would be quite wrong and it's
fascinating all the people who want to
stay in the European Union rather
dislike democracy they don't much want
the next set of European elections and
they certainly didn't like the
referendum and this part the problem
with the EU that it's a scheme of
imposing things on people rather than on
having proper democratic engagement but
yes if we had those elections I would
vote in them and I would always wait for
a Conservative candidate oh talking
about another election lots of people
are are thinking that it may be that a
general election is around the corner
are you concerned like some of your
colleagues that by inviting Jeremy
Corbyn in to thrash out a grexit
compromise to reason may risks
legitimizing him and potentially putting
him in to number 10 well I think you
raise a very important point that there
is a irony the very minimum of saying
one week that one thinks mr corbyn is
dangerous and unfit for office and the
next week deciding to cohabit with him
not both of those statements can be true
and I think the Prime Minister risks
giving a degree of credibility to mr
corbyn and undermining the general
thrust of the conservative argument that
he is a Marxist who would be dangerous
to this nation's interest so yes I think
your fundamental point is right if there
was an election would labour win that's
a really interesting question if you
look at the Newport by-election both the
Labour Party and the Tory parties for
their vote fall are theirs by slightly
more than ours neither party is in touch
with all of its electorate say 70
percent of conservative voters now
identify as levers and the Labour Party
has two electorates one that is very
Prairie man one that is very Pro leave
and the Labour Party is alienating one
part of its electorate so I think it's
simplistic to say that labour would win
simply because the Tories don't look at
the highest point of their fortunes at
the moment
and who if there was to be an election
how'd you like to lead the Conservatives
into that election we know that you've
spoken quite warmly about Boris Johnson
in the past yes well the Prime Minister
has said that she will stand down before
a general election and that's an
important point to remember she's also
said she will stand down
in the event of her deal going through
and so I think it is now legitimate to
be discussing the various abilities of
the different potential candidates and
you're quite right I think very highly
of Boris Johnson who managed to win in
London twice in a labour area has a
great connection with voters is a clear
you're a skeptic but otherwise is very
much in the middle of the Conservative
Party he's not particularly a factional
character beyond the European issue and
therefore I think could unite the party
and win election but we're lucky we have
many other good candidates as well
talking about uniting the party a lot of
people have been talking about the
possibility of what's been known as
Bamber a Boris Johnson amber a dream
ticket is that something that you'd
support well I've always thought highly
of amber rod she's a very long-standing
friend of my sisters as it happens and a
person of first-class capabilities I
happen to disagree with her on the
European issue and there will come a
time though we may find this difficult
to believe at the moment when there are
other things to talk about than Europe
and at that point we will need all the
talents that are arrayed within the Tory
Party not just those it breaks tears I
can't help thinking though that you'd be
in a much better position if you did
want to impose and you need on the
Conservative Party
if brexit is like yourself hadn't moved
too early to launch that confidence vote
against Theresa May the whole picture
would be completely different because it
gave her that protection for a whole
year back in December I've been looking
back with hindsight did you botch it
first of all can I quibble on the word
impes because fortunately the new leader
when that time comes will be voted for
by the mass membership of the
Conservative Party but the general
thrust of your point and these things
are always difficult to time I think had
we had a new leader in December we would
be in the position that we are in now I
think the blame for this model rests
firmly on the Prime Minister's shoulders
would we have a better chance of doing
it now it's very difficult and bare mind
2/3 of backbenchers voted against the
Prime Minister last time and the payroll
is always likely to vote for a leader of
the party because otherwise members of
the payroll ought to resign so and would
we have a better chance now it's hard to
know but what's done is done it's no
good crying over spilt milk